[Musica]
io credo fermamente nel progresso
il tema di questo di questo ted pensate
all'evoluzione che il tema di cui mi
occupo io no l'evoluzione dei viventi
pensate che magnifica storia di
progresso in 3 miliardi e mezzo di anni
ci ha portato dalla mib a a donald trump
se non è progresso questo giusto allora
io vorrei ragionare un po con voi è
progresso naturalmente però per
ragionare un po con voi sulle
ambivalenze del progresso no io ci credo
molto ma insomma dobbiamo valutarlo in
tutti i suoi aspetti
questo signore qua è un mio collega
bravissimo steven pinker si chiama
leggete i suoi libri sono molto ben
scritti molto interessanti uno
scienziato cognitivo un evoluzionista
anche lui ha scritto libri importanti
sull'evoluzione del linguaggio
in particolare però da qualche anno a
questa parte è impegnato in una campagna
culturale filosofica civile
oserei dire vedete il titolo di questo
libro no dobbiamo tornare al
all'illuminismo ai valori
dell'illuminismo e dio sa quanto sia
davvero importante è tornare all'idea di
uno spirito critico dell'esercizio del
dubbio e soprattutto ci tiene a ribadire
steven pinker torniamo a fare
riferimento ai dati alle evidenze che
devono essere il punto di partenza per
ogni ragionamento e le evidenze che lui
racconta nei suoi libri sono alcune come
queste per esempio guardate qua i tassi
di mortalità infantile negli ultimi due
millenni quanto sono crollati quanto
sono diminuiti e questo è un dato
oggettivo è un segno di progresso
oppure guardate l'aspettativa di vita
come si è evoluta nel corso del tempo
dal 1800 250 e poi fino a pochi anni fa
anche qui abbiamo avuto un progresso
straordinario e mappe di questo tipo
potremo vederla per l'accesso all'acqua
e molti altri parametri fondamentali e
questo naturalmente è vero non c'è alcun
dubbio de e fa molto bene pinker a
sottolineare questo perché noi nasciamo
dentro una generazione nativi di una
generazione tendiamo a dare per scontato
quali sono state le conquiste
di chi ci ha preceduto il fatto che si
moriva in modo terribile senza anestesia
o senza antibiotici fino a un secolo un
secolo e mezzo fa
questo è oggettivo ma è sufficiente
questo per stare sicuri che siamo dentro
una traiettoria di progresso se andate a
guardare sempre i dati di pinker ce ne
sono degli altri per esempio noi
consideriamo da un punto di vista
evolutivo anche la crescita della
popolazione
un segno di progresso naturalmente la
puntata strettamente darwiniano lo è il
successo popolaziona le è un segno del
progresso di successo vuol dire che
siamo stati più bravi ad acquisire ea
consumare le risorse altro valore che
viene sempre considerato come tra i
fattori positivi di questo progresso
naturalmente però già lo vedete anche da
quel da come sono come squilibrata
questa crescita potrebbe esserci qualche
problema
se per esempio la nigeria tra qualche
anno avrà più di due terzi della
popolazione di tutta l'europa
tutti i paesi dell'unione europea giusto
quindi dobbiamo stare attenti a capire
bene che cosa c'è dentro c'è questi dati
oppure guardate quest altro dato che
potremmo affiancarlo questo è il
bellissimo report di oxfam che è uscito
qualche mese fa sul tema delle
diseguaglianze
certo ha ragione pinker stiamo
progredendo abbiamo fatto dei passi da
gigante nell'ultimo secolo e mezzo però
non per tutti
non è arrivato a tutti questo guardate
come stanno crescendo le disuguaglianze
a livello globale guardate il numero
delle persone erano 42 17 sono diventate
26 nel 18 che possiedono la stessa
ricchezza di 3 miliardi e mezzo delle
persone più povere oppure guardate jeff
bezos che da solo ha nel suo come suo
patrimonio l'equivalente dell'uno per
cento del budget del budget per la
salute dell'etiopia e l'uno per cento di
tutta la ricchezza di jeff beck
basterebbe un gesto di badge badge per
cambiare completamente i destini
dell'etiopia ci piace un mondo così mica
tanto eppure un mondo che progredisce
però progredisce in modo diseguale in
modo sbilanciato e allora noi che siamo
evoluzionisti dobbiamo sempre analizzare
no quando c'è una tendenza a un trend
che cosa c'è dentro quindi pinchera
ragione però questo è un progresso
innanzi tutto sbilanciato è un progresso
di valente ed è un progresso che non è
per tutti
e poi aggiungerei anche è un progresso
che ha degli effetti collaterali
ce ne sono tanti si parla tanto di
climate change mente di crisi ambientale
anche qui qualche dato secco tanto per
farvi capire secondo natural science che
non sono esattamente due riviste di
militanza ecologista radicale ma sono
due più importanti riviste scientifiche
al mondo ormai homo sapiens ha distrutto
ha fatto fuori
dipende dai gruppi che prendete in
considerazione dal 35 al 40 per cento di
tutti gli altri esseri viventi
c'è una sola specie da sola ha fatto
fuori più di un terzo di tutte le altre
non era mai successo nell'evoluzione e
questa è una pessima idea anche da un
punto vista evoluzionistico per esempio
se calano gli insetti una parte
preponderante delle colture nel mondo
dipendono direttamente o indirettamente
dagli insetti impollinatori
stiamo facendo qualcosa che va anche
contro i nostri interessi oppure
guardate il tema delle nelle plastiche
delle microplastiche anche questa di
padova ci stiamo ci stiamo lavorando e
stiamo cercando di quantificarle tutti
parliamo delle plastiche macroscopiche
la famosa isola no che c'è nel pacifico
migliaia di chilometri di plastica che
galleggia certo una cosa orrenda
terribile però quella la vediamo di
plastica in realtà quella di cui
dobbiamo preoccuparci di più è quella
che anche noi scienziati abbiamo
sottovalutato troppo a lungo sono le
micro plastiche piccolissime quella di
sotto di un terzo di millimetro che
stanno impegnando tutti i mari tutti gli
oceani del mondo il fiume po in italia
dalla pianura padana né riversa migliaia
di tonnellate costantemente
nell'adriatico hanno impregnato
addirittura gli abissi oceanici le micro
plastiche e e noi eppure tre secoli fa
ci siamo dati il nome di homo sapiens
come diceva oscar wilde participio mai
participio fu dato in modo così
frettoloso e certo era un po pessimista
lui d'accordo però provate a pensare
alle microplastiche si infiltrano in
tutti gli animali in quasi la metà dei
cetacei in tutto il mondo ci sono
microplastiche in quasi un terzo dei
pesci compresi quelli che noi ci
mangiamo andiamo a comprare al mercato
quindi noi gettiamo la spazzatura ci
laviamo i tessuti sintetici il pai le
lavatrici buttano queste film nemico
plastica nell'acqua e poi ci mangiamo la
nostra spazzatura homo sapiens
un uomo che fa la spazzatura la butta in
mare e poi se la mangia pensate che la
ln cartour foundation che la più
importante fondazione internazionale che
finanzia ricerche sulla plastica ha
fatto un calcolo che io continuo ad esso
non crederci e mandate a guardare il
calco che hanno fatto e non fa una piega
se ne andiamo avanti così e di anno in
anno continuiamo a pescare pesce come
stiamo facendo adesso in modo
indiscriminato in molte parti del mondo
e in compenso buttiamo dentro plastica e
micro plastica entro il 2050 e come
massa ci sarà più plastica che pesce nei
mari della terra più plastica che pesci
nei mari della terra nel 2050 homo
sapiens
ok c'è un problema evidentemente qua no
che dobbiamo considerare o a noi siamo
evoluzionisti lo consideriamo così senza
mai darne una valutazione etica ma
quantomeno ha inizialmente una
valutazione tecnica scientifica che cosa
sta succedendo sta succedendo quello che
noi esseri umani facciamo da tanto tempo
e che ha decretato il nostro successo
non c'è alcun dubbio
come ha detto una volta grande
evoluzione installa richard lewontin noi
siamo quelli che hanno smesso di
adattarsi all'ambiente rincorrendo i
cambiamenti ambientali ne abbiamo
inventato un'altra strategia
straordinaria potentissima che è quella
di cambiare noi l'ambiente in modo da
renderlo più congeniale alle nostre
esigenze
noi siamo i costruttori della nostra
nicchia ecologica e questo ci ha dato
una grande successo una grandissima
fortuna adesso però c'è un problema e
cominciamo ad accorgersene
ed è un'altra di quelle insidie che
stanno dentro il concetto di progresso
che ripeto io non metto in discussione
ci credo sono ottimista come voi ma
dentro quel concetto di progresso
bisogna essere un po attenti bisogna
restare relativizzano dargli un contesto
cosa sta succedendo con il climate
change e tutti gli esempi che conoscete
bene sta succedendo che adesso noi
dobbiamo anzi scusate i miei figli ei
miei nipoti dovranno adattarsi ai
cambiamenti ambientali che io ho
introdotto nella mia generazione
avete visto nei dibattiti internazionali
sul clima
una volta la parola chiave era
mitigazione giusto cioè eravamo
ottimisti miti chiamo rallentiamo
creiamo un sollievo questo riscaldamento
climatico adesso sono diventati due le
parole d'ordine fondamentali
mitigazione e adattamento c'è ormai è
già successo
dobbiamo adattarci dobbiamo farcene una
ragione dobbiamo cercare di vivere in un
mondo che cambierà a causa dei nostri
della nostra costruzione di nicchia lo
fanno anche altre specie no lo fanno
anche i castori questa una bellissima
vedete una diga del castoro e castoro
cosa fa la stessa cosa costruisce un
artefatto molto bello che è funzionale
per lui per la sua riproduzione la sua
sopravvivenza e così facendo cambia il
mondo perché per esempio crea un lago
crea acqua ferma stagnante che diventa
un ambiente per altre specie
cambia il mondo lo cambia per renderlo
più consono a noi ecco noi siamo castori
andati un po fuori controllo
noi siamo dei castori che si sono fatti
un po prendere la mano
diciamo e quindi climate change per noi
evoluzionistiche cos'è un grande
esperimento evolutivo
so che può sembrare cinico ma è così è
un grande esperimento evolutivo su larga
scala globale che sta cambiando il mondo
favorirà qualche specie invece sarà a
favore di molte altre specie che già
adesso si stanno estinguendo a causa del
cambiamento climatico ma noi noi noi
possiamo salvare davvero il pianeta il
pianeta si salva da solo no ovviamente
noi che cosa possiamo capire qua se
siamo lungimiranti e se siamo
intelligenti che questo pianeta lo
stiamo cambiando in modo talmente veloce
talmente rapido e talmente miope che
rischiamo di pagarne caramente le
conseguenze rischiamo di pagarne cara se
gli ecosistemi non sono più così
generosi con noi in termini di fertilità
avete presente la desertificazione tutti
i problemi connessi al climate change e
in termini di riciclo dell'acqua e così
via
noi dovremo pagare quei servizi
ecosistemici diventeranno più rari gli
economisti sanno che quando qualcosa
diventa raro lo devi pagare quindi
potrebbe essere quella che viene
chiamata una trappola evolutiva c'è
qualche elemento di speranza sì in
realtà perché vedete questo è uno schema
un po astratto per dire la stessa cosa
noi cambiamo il mondo e dobbiamo
adattarci i cambiamenti che noi stessi
abbiamo introdotto e quindi cosa vuol
dire che quando io ho dei figli io ne ho
tre che hanno pressappoco l'età di greta
tubere o poco meno che cosa sto passato
dai miei figli sto passando i miei geni
quelli che ho già passati
mi serve con quelle di mia moglie
naturalmente gli passò delle idee gli
passò la cultura di passo le mie
invenzioni quindi la trasmissione
culturale ma gli sto passando anche i
cambiamenti ambientali che io ho
introdotto nella mia generazione e che
loro si ritrovano loro sono i nativi
climatici quindi i nativi climatici io
spero avranno anche una mentalità
diversa e un'inventiva diversa per poter
venirne fuori perché ci sono nati dentro
ma questo è solo essere una speranza
ripeto da evoluzionisti è sempre bene
ricordare che questa una vecchia storia
noi siamo una specie molto giovane
abbiamo soltanto 200 mila anni e ci
siamo giocati abbastanza bene stata una
tumultuosa meravigliosa evoluzione
abbiamo soltanto 200 millenni ci sono
state soltanto finora 8.000 generazioni
umane e basta io nella mia storia
evolutiva se voglio indietro 4.000 nonni
e basta poi è finita la storia umana
quindi siamo una specie giovanissima ma
anche molto ambivalente
vi faccio un esempio questa è la mappa
delle grandi migrazioni umane no noi
siamo una specie giovane africana uscita
dall africa più volte l'ultima volta 60
mila anni fa
tutti noi siamo tutti discendenti da un
piccolo gruppo di africani circa 60 70
mila persone
tutti i nuovi sette miliardi e mezzo che
sono usciti dall africa quella volta lì
quando sono usciti nell'africa cosa
hanno fatto i nostri pionieri antenati
hanno fatto cose meravigliose bellissime
noi oggi abbiamo scoperto che le pitture
rupestri non sono nati in europa ma sono
state fatte prima queste vengono da sole
gresini indonesia e quindi vuol dire che
già questi primi migranti pionieri che
hanno fondato la specie umana erano
capaci di queste cose meravigliose ma
nello stesso tempo gli stessi gruppi
potevano vivere non soltanto i tropici
all'equatore ma guardate questo mammut
che è stato cacciato nell'artico a meno
22 gradi sotto zero
in un epoca antichissima 45 mila anni fa
cioè i cacciatori africani questi qua
erano di colore
immaginatevi dei masai di oggi vivevano
amen meno venti gradi sotto zero e
cacciavano i mammut chi diavolo glielo
faceva fare l'unica specie al mondo
capace di fare queste cose siamo noi
nessun altro animale vivrebbe in africa
poi parte va a vivere a meno venti gradi
sotto zero mangiando ma mou c'è qualcosa
di profondamente radicato nella
romana in questa ambivalenza no siamo
molto creativi e molto distruttivi
facciamo quella cosa che avete visto
prima
arte rupestre meravigliosa ma ci siamo
anche capaci di grandi capacità di
coordinamento e di organizzazione per
cacciare il mammut e quindi una grande
domanda che resta ancora aperte vedete
questo è il cespuglio dell'evoluzione
umana
guardate quante specie umane ci sono
state sulla terra
tantissime noi siamo l'ultimo ramoscello
là in alto e siamo rimasti da soli
perché abbiamo contribuito
all'estinzione di tutte le altre specie
umane
questo non è tanto progresso no a
eliminare tutti quelli che ti
assomigliano però noi siamo anche questa
cosa qua siamo una specie ambivalente
io qualche anno fa per scherzo a un
congresso internazionale
ho proposto a lisbona ma giuro scherzavo
ho detto scusate voi che vi occupate di
conservazione avete detto che ci sono le
specie in via di estinzione specie
minacciate
introduciamo un'altra categoria le
specie self en danger e quelle che si
sono messe nei guai da soli o che
rischiano di mettersi nei guai da sole e
ci sono due candidati homo sapiens delle
ragioni che vi ho detto
e poi c'è la lch irlandese che il
megalotto che non era un alce non era
irlandese ma adesso non posso farla
lunga che ha contribuito la sua
estinzione con queste corna eccessive
solo che c'è una differenza
la lch hernández e non si è accorta che
si stava estinguendo noi invece abbiamo
tutti gli strumenti per accorgersi che
possiamo esserci infilati in una
trappola evolutiva e che quindi sarebbe
bene uscirne il prima possibile adesso
il che è preoccupante stanno discutendo
se davvero introdurre questa categoria
ma io stavo scherzando è invece
evidentemente bisogna essere preoccupati
quindi io sono molto d'accordo con voi
60 per cento di ottimisti 30 per cento
di incerti 8 per cento di pessimisti
bene dobbiamo essere ottimisti citando
andrea camilleri però con beneficio
d'inventario quindi capisco anche il 30
per cento degli incerti e quindi sono
molto d'accordo con l'esito della vostra
votazione e vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]